[Music]
another supermodel who bounced right
back after baby chrissy teigen Josh and
her hubby John Legend well he's talking
all about family as he gets ready to
receive a big honor we're very happy in
our relationship and very happy to be
parents but like everybody else for
human and we have challenges and so no
one should think that our lives are
perfect
[Music]
the 38 year old Grammy an Oscar winner
can add another title to his long list
he has just been named one of times 100
most influential people in the world but
to 1 year old Luna
he's just dad like other parents were
excited to post pictures of our babies
we're you know when we're having a great
time and we capture a good moment we
want to share with our fridge friends is
the theme in this year's time 100 list
online tomorrow Emma Stone is honored by
her bestie brie Larson who calls her the
wise psychiatrist the fearless leader
the coolest girl at the party
[Music]
James Corden's pal Elton John pays
tribute to the carpel King saying his
authenticity has allowed him to shape
pop culture in an incredible way nice
guy and Helen Mirren calls her woman in
gold co-star Ryan Reynolds the real deal
you have an unusual talent for making me
feel good about myself with really great
chemistry we were like fire in a dry
house
she's even my next-door neighbor in our
hotel miron telling time quote he's the
everyman but somehow with more of
everything with elegant looks and
general hunkiness I must have done
something right in my life to have had
the opportunity to work with Ryan
[Music]